Film Courage: When did you decide on documentary
filmmaking?
Your first film was a narrative or was it…there
wasn’t really a decision?
There was an interest sparked for something?
Matthew Miele, filmmaker (ALWAYS AT THE CARLYLE):
So my thinking behind it was I did a second
a narrative called Eavesdrop and then that
had a very hard time getting out there.
So I was very discourage because I was trying
to figure out well how am I going to tell
the stories I want to tell?
And then you have this huge mountain to climb
with raising money and the cast.
You have a very small amount of time to get
it right with a feature because it’s only
like a four or five-week on-set experience
and there are such long days.
And I really was discouraged with the process
of storytelling and the feature and the feature
narrative.
However, from those two directing gigs (because
I’d gotten notice from some writing) because
I had written scripts.
So I came out here [Los Angeles] and I was
doing some writing and I got a manager and
I was working with an agency.
And I started working with a couple of high-profile
directors on a couple of scripts and I was
helping to do a couple of things.
But ultimately I got discouraged because with
that you sometimes are on turn around on a
lot of things, you don’t get credited if
you work on something and you know, you’re
in that development thing.
And sometimes your work doesn’t really pay
off because you can be working on something
for so long and never gets made.
So then I had this frustration point where
I was like “I just want to tell my stories.
How can I do this a lot easier in a sense?”
And I’m a New Yorker in my heart and as
a child used to come into the city and see
the windows at Bergdorf Goodman and a variety
of different storefronts.
And I remember that as a kid and I used to
look up at these different windows and say
“Wow, that’s like my first approach and
first encounter with storytelling and a three-act
structure you could see within just one window.
And I just absorbed that and I said to myself
“You know what?
I’d love to do a film on Bergdorf’s because
that was my first encounter with this window
(windows).
I approached them and they said we don’t
allow filming and to do a whole feature would
be crazy because you’d have to buy the store
out and film and it’s multi, multi millions
to even think about it.
But then I said “Well let me look at your
archive.
Let me do a little more research on the place.”
They showed me their archive and it was so
thin and I was like “Well, you don’t keep
a formal archive?
Well I’m surprised it’s not huge it’s
a hundred years old.
And they said no.
And I said well let’s do a project together.
I’ll beef up your archive with interviews
and we’ll figure it out together.
And I said “Let’s do a documentary”
And they said “Okay.”
So for the next two years we were rolling
camera.
And you can green light your project like
that without all the money you need to get
it done.
And also there’s this protracted period
where you can work on something for a longer
period of time at your own pace and you don’t
have to have that really concentrated thing.
And it was in 2011 when I started to think
about that and that’s when the doc started
to get hot and get like this golden period
(which I still think we’re going through).
And I feel like storytelling in a doc form
is a really refreshing approach if you really
want to get your thing or your film made and
out there because you can literally for $1,000-$2,000
bucks have a camera, start rolling and green
light your own project.
It’s really about picking the right topic,
getting the right people that you want to
interview or highlight and just making a compelling
story.
And if you stitch that all together successfully
you can get something out there in a theatrical
way just as much as a feature narrative is
these days.
I mean my last four docs all went to theaters
and they were rated and you feel like you’re
doing it and in it.
But it was a byproduct and a result of my
frustration with the features side.
So I’m kind of like in the doc world right
now (about to do two more that are already
shot) but I’m entering back into the feature
world now because I got attached to direct
this film on Norman Rockwell.
It’s a biopic on that iconic artist.
So I’m really excited about that so I’m
kind of like entering back in.
But I feel better now because I’ve accomplished
what I’ve needed to in the doc world and
I feel like with that experience I’ll bring
more to my directing prowess when I get on
set and do that next thing.